[Music]
the base combat shotgun is good for
staggering zombies basically if you
shoot them in a medium distance it's
almost a guaranteed stagger so you will
get a glory kill almost guaranteed if
you shoot them in a close range it'll
iterate them and people will feel that
right away and then the mods it's hard
not to talk about the mods the sticky
bomb is one of the most efficient ways
to remove weak points on many enemies
it's like a drug
yeah actually to do it it's amazing
because the weak points make a like a
plink sound when you hit them so when
you get good at like lobbing sticky
bombs whether it's the you know the Arak
neutrons turret or the the Menk Ulysses
guns or the revenants guns you you get
to this Zen point of basically being
able to lob it and then look away and
hear that pinging sound and and it's
just it's it's so thrilling
that is good again a really good fodder
control weapon that can give you the
level of precision in terms of the
number of bullets you could put an enemy
to guarantee a falter a stager when you
really need it so I used that quite a
bit on Em's for example to stagger them
when I need glory kills the horoscope is
a more advanced way to take off weak
points where you could quickscope
enemies and do it really fast so the I
kind of think of it like the the sticky
bomb is like the entry level weak point
removal gun and then the horoscope is
more of the advanced one where you could
do it from across the arena and then the
micro missiles similarly allow you like
a you know rapid fire output of micro
missiles that can burn down an enemy
pretty quick I was a micro missile fiend
on 2016 and have actually kind of
shifted a little bit more to favor the
scope because it is just so effective
against weak points to show you some of
the thought that goes into the balance
the micro missiles will not remove weak
points so even if I empty an entire
chamber and I have it mastered and it's
just a hose of death you can never take
off weak points and you don't ever get a
falter like they're very hard to falter
with micro missiles so you have full
movement with micro missiles and they
home but you don't get the falters that
you do from other weapons and you can't
strip off weak points and when you
remove a weak point you also get a
falter so a stagger is when they glow a
falter is when they have like a pain
reaction and when they do that they stop
attacking so a deep meta especially on
nightmare that starts to become a big
part of players games is what falters
enemies because it basically makes them
a non threat in that moment
that is basically for shield guys and
you can take a shield guys blue shield
and turn it into a bomb and if you shoot
it and break it it creates this huge a a
wee blast that will kill enemies around
them so I was like one of the number one
uses for that gun
then the mod the microwave mod slows
them down you could lock them down and
basically cook them until they explode
which now we're talking about like which
tool is right for the right enemies like
the the whiplash for example is
extremely elusive and very dangerous so
being able to lock her down and
basically get her to stop moving is
pretty critical and the microwave mod is
great for that
the Heatblast mod it's just a great
crowd control mod it's it's you're gonna
get a benefit for leaning on the weapon
and then you get a huge like basically
shotgun blast mid-round and then when
you master it you actually get a couple
seconds of extra power from the weapon
slow moving but super powerful huge
amount of self damage lock-on certainly
make killing things like the prowler or
the whiplash which are elusive enemy
types extremely it's very useful for
those guys and then the remote detonate
certainly good for craft control but
it's very much a throwback to the
original rocket launcher like powerful
animals hard to come by ammo capacity is
low and if you try to use it like a
rifle and spam it and just run around
with it to kill zombies you're probably
gonna get yourself killed so it's a good
example of so much of what we did in
doom eternal it's it's a thinking
person's action game
the super shotgun is the most powerful
weapon in the game at point-blank range
I think I could say that with confidence
that is your your your super uppercut
but it's slow and and you got to be real
close so you're not gonna be able to
just run up to people and just uppercut
them without any kind of retaliation
from the AI so you want to set it up
with something and then obviously the
meathook which I demonstrated is
critical to advanced levels of movement
that you'll need especially on the
higher difficulties you can move it to
close distances expert plays I'll use it
I'll switch to that just to meet hook
across the arena to chainsaw on enemy or
to get to an enemy really fast just to
glory kill them or to use it to launch
me off of an enemy and do all kinds
things so the mobility involved with the
meathook is pretty critical more
effective against flying enemies if you
go to the Codex it will specify which
gun is more effective against - so one
of the mods on the ballista the árboles
it's like a charged up bow and arrow
shot a single shot at six one enemy and
then explodes that will take out a
Cacodemons in one shot so it's really
really effective against flying enemies
now the flying enemies have been tuned
accordingly that they'll actually dodge
a little bit out of the way depending on
who you're fighting with so you can't
just sit there with your reticle on them
forever and then there's the destroyer
blade which you charge up and lets out a
giant blade throughout the space and
pretty much killed anything it touches
but there's a huge risk reward there
because your movement is severely
limited and it takes a long time to
charge up overall though it's a great
combo weapon and another kind of
advanced weapon for removing weak points
you have the utility of the chain gun is
huge people don't realize that yet but
they will the stopping power of the
chain gun against the heavy charging the
the pressure units like the the dread
Knight and the hell Knight enter and the
Baron is huge so those enemies are
really tough in the game like a dread
Knight is like lethal and to light him
up with the micro missiles is pretty
effective you know but it's not gonna
slow him down the mobile turret you know
is the strongest in the game I mean you
could put out more DPS back on then
than any other weapon and then the
shield mod for it it's great yeah it
just went when stuff gets thick at the
end of the game and you're just like
dude I need to kill things and just give
me like two seconds with a shield see
it's awesome like it I use it all the
time it's really really powerful and
when you master it you can you can - in
the guys and and fall to them yes super
weapons that are balanced for the
encounters and certainly some encounters
in late-game we'll be encouraging the
player to use them but we know that the
best players don't really want to fire
their nuke because that's kind of like
you want to take on the challenge
without shooting off your nukes a lot of
the super heavies in some cases are
resistant to super weapons and some like
you could cut down a tyrant with the
crucible blade strike you know pretty
good if you ever want to go mano-a-mano
with some of our best enemies it's very
useful to shoot the BFG into the air
you'll get rid of all the white belts
and you and the black belt can dance
super fun if you if you feel yourself
being overwhelmed it's probably because
we want you to to launch one of those
nukes or just get good and beat them got
it out
[Music]
you